[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
welcome good friday
[Music]
how are you
good morning good morning to everyone
yoda's here patty's here nolan's here
and here jay is here christina's here
everyone's here hi hi hi hello hello and
good morning
um we have a lot of news to get to today
we're going to do bonehead of the week
as well i've had a lot of people send me
a lot of things over the last few days
uh about russia
and the ukraine that
vladimir putin that murderous [ __ ]
dictating tyrant
like we've been saying the last few days
um
as [ __ ] is on the road to
the typical the typical standoff with
the tyrant for sure
um it seems as if
vladimir putin's days may be numbered i
always thought maybe this guy would rule
for another 10 or 15 years but the way
that he doesn't give a [ __ ] anymore
he's gonna go for the power grab no
matter what
some of the [ __ ] war crimes that seem
to be committed here that piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
on the ukrainian people and the
ukrainian people have stood
strong and proud
uh against this [ __ ] there's also
there's people there that could have
left
could have went away
to another country lived a great life
nope they're standing and fighting for
their country
hey you hey you dumb [ __ ]
anti-vaxxers
hey you [ __ ] stupid ottawa truckers
or whatever the [ __ ] you were
think you're [ __ ]
you're fighting for freedom and [ __ ]
you ain't got no [ __ ] clue
what it feels like to fight for
democracy freedom and liberty you ain't
got a [ __ ] clue go look at some of
the [ __ ] pictures
of not just ukraine and the people
fighting there go look at some of the
[ __ ] pictures of the protest in
russia
where these people would be murdered
murdered oh i can't get a whopper
because i chose not to get vaccinated so
that way i could get other people sick
in the restaurant and i can't have a
whopper i'm oppressed
you little [ __ ] you have no idea what
oppression is
outside of your cozy little [ __ ]
white democracy
go look at the [ __ ] images go look at
them
know what courage for freedom actually
is
it's amazing to see that many people in
the streets
and russia
chanting no more no to war
they don't want war in russia
especially with ukraine they don't want
war
and putin really doesn't want war with
ukraine either he wants no
democracy
that's what he wants
and we have an entire party in this
country that is cheering him on let's
not forget that these [ __ ]
aren't gonna back away from what they
said [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
you own that [ __ ] now [ __ ]
and we should hold them to account
about their anti-democratic ways in
their anti-democratic speech and
cheering on a murderous [ __ ] tyrant
like putin thinking he's some kind of
[ __ ] tough guy
well we know who's tough now
we know
it's the ukrainian people and the
russian people who are the [ __ ] tough
ones who are resilient
some of the images coming out of ukraine
tanks rolling over passenger cars you
sick [ __ ]
it's disgusting it's vile
bombing apartment buildings residential
areas
no he's not he's not holding back at all
for what's about to come to putin
if putin thinks he's going to retire
somewhere to a nice fancy little island
oh
baby i bet i bet walmart gaddafi and
saddam hussein would have something to
say about that
they didn't get that retirement plan did
they
so we shall see how long putin's reign
lasts
murdering innocent women children and
citizens of ukraine
all in your in your quest
for people to question democracy so you
can reign in power forever well
i have a feeling your power's about to
end
we're going to go through the shitless
roundup today i'm i'm hoping we have
rachel bitkoffer here gabe is going to
join us as well
maybe gabe will talk to rachel with us
and we're going to do bonehead of the
week
by the end of the show at some point
bonehead of the week has kind of taken a
backseat this week because we've had all
this russian news
and we're going to play that interview
hopefully on monday or tuesday i know
we've we've kind of put it on the back
burner because of the news yesterday and
we have both end of the week today but
we do want to play that interview for
you guys i know you guys are waiting on
that interview about the the gibson go
data dump
out of the ottawa truckers convoy you've
seen did you see the convoy in dc ah
that kind of went over like a wet fart
in a white thong didn't it
oh we're gonna shut down the academy
we're gonna [ __ ] lock it up joe
biden's gonna suffer oh really
one truck you got one truck to show up
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
one [ __ ] truck
fantastic
it just goes to show you that it's all
bluster it's all [ __ ] it's all
staged
the same way putin is staging his war
against ukraine
i tried to stage his war against ukraine
you know he tried to get him to
retaliate that way he could tell the
russian people see they're trying to go
to war with us
see look look they're trying to go to
war with us we have to fight them
because the russian people are having
none of this [ __ ]
none of this [ __ ]
all right let's get into the uh
the shitless round up here i i believe
um
let's start the countdown here in just a
second
but we're gonna have the shitless
roundup we're gonna have rachel
bitcoffer join us at some point in the
show i believe rachel's gonna join us
and then we'll have gabe we'll do bone
end of the week
so stay tuned
through the entire two hours today you
guys know we do two hours every single
week day noon eastern 11 central right
here on youtube twitter twitch and if
you're on youtube go you know like it
share it
the you know what whatever it is comment
down below that you're supposed to do on
youtube do that
and also share it with your friends this
thing is also
up on all
the podcast directories spotify apple
google all the ones that you even want
to boycott it's up there it's up on
there you can find it
anywhere you download your podcast
you can find the tony michael spots this
so go download it and also do me a huge
favor
do gabe and i and the show a huge favor
and give us a five star rating give us a
rating there whether it's at apple
spotify wherever i know a lot of people
don't like spotify but if you're not on
spotify that's fine go to apple go to
google wherever you download your
podcast
go there leave us a five star review
tell us what you think
be be gentle gabe doesn't get his
microphone on all the time exactly when
he should but it get go easy on him
i like to give gabe [ __ ] about his
microphone
so go do that also if you want to
support the podcast we really appreciate
all the likes shares retweets
invite your friends show them
maybe i i don't know i i've been
floating the idea that we would
broadcast this on facebook too i've been
toying with the idea we're on youtube
twitter twitch right now i got a
facebook page you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
and you go to my facebook page
um there i it just i i don't know i'm
not i'm not
that that
that
enthralled with with facebook but we
might go over there maybe get some more
audience members maybe some more people
to share and like
spread the message around a little bit
get them over here on youtube so they
can chat with you during the show
you know that sort of thing
so go to thetonymichaels.com while
you're there check out the podcast
upgrade fun also check out the merch
store
there on thetonymichaels.com the link is
in my bio also follow
our podcast page on twitter at
tonymichaelspot go do that as well
you know we have we have something very
uh cool that i want to show today um
even though war is not always
what it's cracked up to be for sure but
there is a very cool story about the
ghost of kiev
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome to the shitless
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends of today oh
my gosh there's a ton of [ __ ] to round
up today um we not only have uh the war
in ukraine where the
murderous dictator vladimir putin we
also have a supreme court nominee that
is very big news here in the united
states uh the first
black woman
and to be nominated to the supreme court
and i actually this was
katanji was my pick i wanted katanji
from the very beginning um a lot of
people said she's too liberal i'm like
well maybe she's not [ __ ] liberal
enough now the other nice part is it
really shits in paul ryan's cereal i
don't know if you guys seen this but
that she's related to paul ryan by
marriage
and uh
paul ryan actually released a tweet this
morning
uh the guy the guy seems to be wanting
to run for president at some point in
his life um otherwise he
otherwise otherwise
he wouldn't have said what he said
so
we'll see everybody's here this morning
i'm glad to have everybody here
christina is here caitlin's back hi
caitlin welcome back
well let's see
who else we got you got mikey
on twitch there's there's still people
over on twitch
and's here robin's here and i to i want
to thank you guys for sending all um
over the last few days um yesterday and
today and uh in between time um everyone
who sent links to some of this russian
stuff some of the videos i know we
played a lot of video yesterday of the
things that were going on in ukraine um
with the vladimir putin and also in
russia with the protest i really want i
really appreciate you guys sending me
all that stuff
um and we'll play some of it here today
some of the stuff that you guys sent us
on the [ __ ] list roundup i actually
retweeted a lot of it so it's right on
the timeline so let's just go straight
to the timeline here let's go straight
to time let's make it a little bigger
let's see
okay
um
first off uh kalyn uh sent this
uh i don't know if you guys seen this
and i think we showed
i don't know if we showed we talked
about it uh yesterday i believe the um
they had portable crematoriums that the
russians were hauling in behind the tank
regiments right so like they're soldiers
marching
and here they are having the pool along
the [ __ ] crematorium that their
bodies are going to be cr cremated in so
that way putin can hide the [ __ ]
bodies
i think we brought it up yesterday uh
caitlyn says putin is a sick
[ __ ] no [ __ ] that's the tweet
that's all you need really uh the daily
mail online russian mothers say their
sons were tricked into joining putin's
army i don't know if you guys also seen
that there was a regiment of
of troops that had surrendered i guess i
don't know the exact number it's kind of
hard to tell but i guess there was a
regiment of troops who had surrendered
to the ukrainians um because they didn't
know they were there to kill ukrainians
they had no [ __ ] clue that they were
there to kill ukrainians
that do oh my which that that would have
been nice to know wouldn't it
if uh if the if putin would have let
them know that they were there to
to murder ukrainians because it's not a
war just no war
there was no instigation
putin attacked a sovereign country
because he wants to take a sovereign
country that's why article 4 was
instituted and i believe that article 5
is going to be instituted if it hasn't
been already but i i think it's going to
be
all right here's the here's the tweet
about the paul ryan uh uh if you go up
here
uh
the best part about kantanji brown
jackson's nomination is her eight-year
district court record was already vetted
with her confirmation hearing in the dc
circuit she was just confirmed um to the
dc circuit she's only been on the dc
circuit for eight months
so not much of a
record to
vet she should sail through and she
should sail through you know the reason
why she'll sail through and she should
sail through and democrats and slam dunk
her nomination and not not give a [ __ ]
about what one republican says not a
[ __ ]
not a [ __ ] not one goddamn [ __ ] none to
give
because amy coney barrett that's why
[ __ ] [ __ ] them
slam dunk this [ __ ] get her to
be the supreme court justice in five
[ __ ] days let's set another goddamn
record [ __ ] them i i think packed the
court
i think if we could find five katanji
brown jacksons to put on the court let's
do that [ __ ] them
that's what they want to do let's do it
uh also
c he says republican senators already
vetted her
back in 2013 and again in 2021
republicans have voted for her they're
[ __ ] here
dee that did that [ __ ] paul ryan is
her brother-in-law through marriage
oh [ __ ] no that's hilarious
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] what a
ding-a-ling
this guy's running for president though
for sure for sure this guy's running for
president have you seen his tweet this
morning
if you've seen this tweet maybe we'll
find it here maybe we'll find it here
all right let's go back to the timeline
oh
that's not where we want to go uh we'll
go here there we go okay
um
i think uh oh this is the video i think
caitlyn sent this to me i haven't
watched it but
um she says it's funny so let's play
this thing
foreign
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you dj fm and thank you
hale ever sending that i love i love
that scene in the avengers
puny god
puny god
fantastic fantastic okay let's let's go
back to the timeline here um this is a
video this is a video here of the what
people are calling it goes to kiev i
believe i think that's what they're
showing here um it's not a very long one
apparently um this fighter pilot has
taken down i think six russian aircraft
which is like
um
you know it makes him a god
among other air pilots let's watch
how [ __ ] cool is that
yeah
uh and the rumors from the ukraine front
line calling a fighter pilot the ghost
of kiev alleges he is down six russian
jets already this hits hard
this hits hard yeah it does
all right um i can't give credit cause
the comments are off here
everyone must have
been going after um here's another ghost
of kiev
meme uh it says putin russian is doing
military exercise in ukraine it goes to
kiev and i took that personally
yeah [ __ ] russians shoot down every one
of the last of those jets i seen a video
last night and maybe i uh you retweet it
so we can see it um it was actually of a
a fighter jet or i believe i believe it
was um
i believe it might have been
a helicopter that was taken down
let's see what else do we have
oh see i'm i'm i'm getting off track
here there we go okay um that that did
uh okay the eu is preparing to freeze
the assets of vladimir putin his foreign
minister sergey lairva
lavrov excuse me under a new sanctions
package the financial times reports
putin and lavrov will not be subject to
a ban on traveling
um that's [ __ ]
they should lock all these [ __ ]
down and they should freeze more than
just their assets i'm saying put them on
ice is what i'm saying
freeze more than their assets for sure
okay let's move on down the the the
timeline
um oh this is uh caitlyn pointed this
out this is this is some video from
russia like we were talking about
earlier
uh that these these little freedom
fighters here in the united states and
canada the freedom fighters who are
fighting freedom
i don't understand that crime fighters
fight crime firefighters fight fire what
if freedom fighters fight as george
garland says now caitlyn says
it's not lost on me that the same people
praising putin are the same ones who
spent last week whining about the
canadian truckers being arrested after
three weeks of occupying ottawa for no
[ __ ] reason really other than
someone paid them and told them to
careful what you wish for gop this is
how protesters would be handled on day
one in putin's russia are putin's
america
putin's america how about that that's
what they [ __ ] want tucker carlson
and fox news you [ __ ] gross
[ __ ] okay let's listen let's
watch what happens when you dissent in
russia for i don't know a couple hours
those whiny little [ __ ] in ottawa
wouldn't last five [ __ ] minutes
not five [ __ ] minutes hello debbie
welcome welcome
it's okay if you're late that's okay you
can subscribe to the youtube channel and
you can always re-watch our episodes
rather you missed yesterday's episode
today's episode i'll episode last week
you can always watch here
let's retweet this and give some credit
for this video in this tweet watch
wrestling police overwhelm force
to swiftly arrest
uh
evidently peaceful anti-ukraine war
protesters they were chanting no to war
no to war
no to war
okay let's see here give kaelin credit
here
all right let's go back
um this is a great story uh mayor of
kiev kiev and i'm gonna say the name
because i'll get it wrong defending his
country this is a great story um if you
go down uh he is a former boxing
champion and a millionaire he's rich
he could have fled the ukraine by
private jet
lived a happy life elsewhere but he
decided to fight for his country instead
and risk his life
glory to ukrainian heroes
this guy is a hero
putin doesn't know what tough is do you
think putin would fight
you think he would fight like actually
fight
like really [ __ ] fight like this guy
he wouldn't flee
how long do you think before putin runs
or ends up in a [ __ ] bunker somewhere
because he's a [ __ ] afraid little
[ __ ]
then then then what the what is the gqp
gonna say oh we love him he's so tough
he's so strong
he's so strong
he's not strong you dumb [ __ ] he's weak
this guy
this guy the mayor of kiev
is the one who's strong he could have
fled and he didn't
he's standing to find against putin and
the russian army
morgan's putin and the russian army
probably
um here is the president of ukraine
president zielinski
that's what a president looks like huh
all dressed out and garb like that with
a helmet i mean that you know this is
common stuff
this is normal stuff
you know
this is the way democracies are supposed
to work
look
i mean how could there not a president
not be dressed like this on any average
day in a democracy
nothing nothing to see here
are you are you [ __ ] are you
right wingers you [ __ ] nazis out
there figuring out what what it looks
like to turn the world over to putin are
you understanding yet what it means to
have marjorie taylor green
matt gatz and others
to [ __ ] be in charge of our
government those [ __ ] you want tucker
carlson to be in charge
that's what you want steve bannon that
[ __ ] traitor
because they'll do they'll do just as
bad or worse than putin is
open your [ __ ] eyes pluck your head
out of your ass and understand what it
what is happening in ukraine
it's not just a war in ukraine with
russia that's what the right wing wants
here for you dummy
okay let's go here's another picture of
um
this is president zielinski and the
quote is this may be the last time you
see me alive
he's come to terms with that
he's come to terms in that
um and saying he saw a russian official
fell out the window this morning
yeah we uh kalyn says she'd like to read
that story yeah and if you've got that
story on twitter
uh either dm it to me or someone else
and we'll try to pull that up if we can
we'll try to we'll try to get that going
if we can if you'll if you'll send that
in a dm or just tag me on the on the
post we'll try to find that we'll try to
find that did it do
uh christina said that's what a real
patriot looks like i think that's i
think you're talking about the the mayor
and even even the president
he's not hiding in a bunker either
he's out with the with he's out there
he's not cowering away from these [ __ ]
uh let's see
ann says could you picture old bone
spurs fighting like that
oh fighting for what fighting over the
the front of the buffet line
is that is that it
no i couldn't i couldn't see him
fighting for anything
hails to the no hails didn't know let's
see here uh
here's some more stuff kaelin sent
confirmed burned down
um
news this second says breaking members
of hack hacking collective anonymous
have taken down the russian news uh
website i don't know if this had
anything to do you know me and gabe were
uh talking about this yesterday and we
kind of found the tweet that that the
the
the kremlin's uh website and a lot of
the russian government's websites have
been taken down so i don't know if that
was part of this
um i don't know if that was part of this
anonymous hack where they took this
stuff down
but
it could seem to be related you know
yesterday we were either saying well it
could be like russia was shutting it
down to try to stave off communications
um so they couldn't communicate with the
government
or through the government website to
create any um anti-you know anti-war
protests
or it could have been um outside forces
you know whether it be america the
allies or maybe anonymous so maybe that
had something to do with it
but there is a confirmation here um that
it was that was it was down i don't know
is it still down does anyone know
um let's see let's go to uh rrt.com
let's see
no it is up again rt.com is up again
it's up
i don't know if that's significant or
not i don't know
how they made that happen but
uh thanks for pointing that out kaylin
appreciate it oh i already said that
okay let's see
uh
there's the there's the the tweet that's
why i wanna
thank you for your tweet
okay let's see um
no casler has a great um
take here you guys like noel i like noel
i like his car rants
we've had jimmy kennedy on before the
show here his executive producer of his
podcast
jimmy's a great guy and noel's a great
guy but these these insights into trump
and trump putin and russia is uh very
intriguing the way that noel breaks it
down because noah was on the apprentice
he was on the crew of the apprentice so
he was right there he seen it he was a
part of it right in the mix so let's
listen to what noel says about
russia putin and [ __ ]
the cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy
pants himself trump pack and house
relates to world events the very first
cpac after trump became president in
february of 17 they handed out russian
flags with trump's name on them and the
audience started waving them around
until they realized what was going on
and the cpac people started grabbing
them up and they said they were tricked
they weren't tricked they were sending a
message okay putin was sending a message
to the united states with trump the
whole time people forget mark burnett
wanted to make a show with putin he
wanted to do a show on the space station
and the oligarchs and stuff in russia
and putin's people said no you want to
do a show on donald trump our guy in new
york city who's a real estate developer
that's how the apprentice started okay
it was the russians that put them on to
trump most people forget that okay
not to mention that the after parties at
celebrity apprentice were like russian
mobster meet and greets felix sater
would work the room with the trump
organization business card and make
introductions between these mobster
types and jared and ivanka you know and
don jr who was kind of sober in those
days
right he was dry at least right they'd
work the room it was a jobs summit okay
for getting cash out of the soviet union
why do you think trump's obsessed with
like south miami you know he wants that
russian cash okay that's who trump is
that's how he started in new york city
before trump built trump tower you'd
have to get past a co-op board to buy
into a you know a fancy building and
park your money right they weren't going
to just take anybody trump came up you
know he didn't invent the idea of condos
but he was the first guy to do it in new
york city on a large scale like you got
the cash i'll sell you an apartment no
questions asked right and that's rife
for exploitation from money laundering
and corruption and also espionage which
goes hand in hand with the entire
operation he was running out of trump
tower you know there was brothels in
that joint there was poker dance and
there was people spying on each other
and they're damn sure were spying on
trump because he had a free pass to all
the brothels so he'd go up there and
find his little vonkey look alike and
have a good time not thinking about the
fact oh
you can see it all over trump's face he
was busted
his look-alike funky
oh man the cuts are deep with no uh he's
he he doesn't he doesn't get the you
know
really
loud and boisterous like me but
uh no does great car rants and the cuts
are deep okay now let's go on here um uh
christopher pointed out here this was
the plan the whole time no one shouldn't
be surprised that uh trump republicans
praising the dictator who's determined
to undermine u.s interests and democracy
itself i don't know if you guys remember
this
but back in 2016
during the the republican uh national
convention
during that time the trump campaign
worked behind the scenes
to make sure that the new republican
platform wouldn't call for giving
weapons to ukraine to fight russia
and rebel forces contradicting the view
of almost all republican foreign policy
leaders at the time in washington listen
they have
putin has been planning to do this for a
long time he used trump to make sure
that they didn't have weaponry the good
part is is it didn't work because
trump's a [ __ ] idiot
i i really think putin has miscalculated
here
dramatically
dramatically not just not just with
trump thinking that trump really fixed
it up for him
but also also
to to doubt that the united states
could make sure even with trump
that we did not that we our democracy
will not crumble
that national security and foreign
policy
would stay firm
even with that [ __ ] buffoon because
let's face it everyone keeps saying oh
well this wouldn't happen under trump of
course
of course vladimir putin wouldn't go to
war with ukraine but trump why would he
he would let trump who would be the
president united states dismantle
ukraine
why would he do what someone else would
do in return he does he's not gonna do
that he's doing it now because there was
no [ __ ] and if or but about ukraine
being our ally and having democracy and
us helping defend them from russia
if anyone but trump was president of the
united states snoopy bugs bunny or or
joe biden
that's why
that's why
putin invaded ukraine
he has no other choice
to extend his quote-unquote reign
he knows democracy is knocking he know
democracy is coming look at the people
in russia
look at the people in russia here
right here alexander vinman post
pushkin square maybe less than a
thousand meters from red square in the
kremlin and the kremlin is the site of a
significant protest
these people know the risk of
challenging the regime they're on the
streets in spite of major personal costs
[Music]
look at this look at these people
take a look take a look ottawa truckers
take a look at look anti baxters take a
look january sixers you [ __ ]
this is what democracy looks like
this is what pro-democracy looks like
standing against a murderous dictator
that you [ __ ] want
that donald trump
placates to so much so that he he even
says on stage in front of a microphone
as innocent ukrainian women and children
are being [ __ ] murdered by vladimir
putin and his army
by invading a sovereign country because
he just can't [ __ ] help his dictaria
ways
stands on stage and says well putin's
smart
why wouldn't he take a country for two
dollars worth of sanctions
donald trump would have sold out every
[ __ ] one of us
every [ __ ] one of us
he would have sold out all of america if
all it meant was just oh well that's a
great investment
democracy
democracy is hard it's not easy
because authoritarian ways really are
attractive when one person can fix
everything
especially to authoritarian right
wingers
like donald trump
oh he wants to be putin so bad oh man
what a great deal what a great deal like
it's some kind of [ __ ] real estate
transaction
what a great deal
what a great deal
kailyn says
could we get a show of hands of how many
people want no castler on the show i
would love to have noel i like i said
i've had jimmy before i think jimmy's
been on the show two or three times i
would love to have noah on the show
and know that if you're out there
listening if you're out there listening
noel you i have an open invitation to
come on the show i would love to talk
about the apprentice
and trump
and how it relates to mark burnett and
russia
that would be fantastic
okay
thank you
um alexander vinman for your tweet here
for this video for your insight under
that
of how dangerous this is um lindy lee
even said about this video i'm crying
the bravery of russian people is
inspiring putin is already rounding up
at least 1745 people in 54 russian
cities this monstrous man has
miscalculated yep you are correct the
russian people do not want to invade
their ukrainian neighbors family and
friends that is right the other thing
that's going to really [ __ ] bite
putin in the ass here
really bite him in the [ __ ] ass
is that these people are gonna get to
see the power of democracy
and that's what he's trying to avoid
but in his quest to avoid it he's only
pointing it out even louder and clearer
clearer
i said this morning the world needs to
freeze much more than just putin and
lavrov's assets
put them on ice
it's time the world gets serious about
this tyrant
it's time
okay let's go to the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends of the day off the
timeline and let's make it over to the
trending list
again training number one is supreme
court
uh katangi brown jackson is nominated to
the supreme court if confirmed she would
become the first black woman to serve as
justice
what
what a fantastic
fantastic move
that joe biden made during the campaign
to make sure that he told people i will
make sure that the court looks like
america
i will make sure
that the court looks like america by
nominating a black woman
that was his assurance
and he held up to his assurance he he
kept his promise that he would nominate
a black woman to make sure that the
court looked like america and i believe
this is what american leadership looks
like right here in the president's tweet
i'm proud to announce that i am
nominating judge contangi brown jackson
to serve on the supreme court currently
she's serving the u.s court of appeals
for the d.c circuit she is one of our
nation's brightest legal minds
and will be an exceptional justice this
actually tears at my heart a little bit
i'm i'm very excited to see a face
like katangi brown jackson's on the
supreme court and i think we need more
of this i think this is what american
leadership looks like take a good hard
long look
black women are the most educated
population in our country the most
educated the smartest the brightest you
goddamn right there should be more
female black judges everywhere not just
on the supreme court
i believe this is the direction our
country is going and i am proud of it
i think it's exactly what we need
the sooner we get women in power and
control the quicker they can clean up
the mess that these [ __ ] men have
made
it's about time
barack obama says i want to congratulate
judge contangi brown jackson on her
nomination to the supreme court judge
jackson has already inspired young black
women like my daughters to set their
sights higher
and her confirmation will help them
believe they can be anything they want
to be
that only speaks to it
that speaks to it thank you
barack obama for your tweet
i think i think we should also
uh not steer from this
what we should do
what the what the president and the
senate and we should do especially if we
win these midterms big
you know i mean we're fighting against
uh putin here and i don't think it's
going to be hard to pen putin on these
[ __ ] these
these right-wing gq peers here they're
going to be pen to putin here that's
right we should pin them up as putin's
puppets because that's what they are
not going to be that hard now
and what we should do
is expand the court
fully expand the court make the court
look like the country put more black
women on that court there's plenty of
qualified black women out there to be a
supreme court nominee let alone a
supreme court justice we've seen the
list that the president was considering
now again
katangi was my favorite because she is
one of the quote unquote most liberal
i think we should put more liberal
people on the court more and more
liberal [ __ ] them [ __ ] them they they
got amy coney barrett they got what they
wanted
they got what they wanted so we should
get what we want [ __ ] them that's how we
should do it you want to play politics
fine play politics with the court
let's see
dude is there any um footage here
on katangi
again you know that she was just
nominated just nominated and just
confirmed uh to the dc court less than a
year ago
which is significant because she's
already been she's already been
confirmed in last year to a seat
shouldn't take long
shouldn't take long to figure out that
she's qualified to be on the supreme
court
they just did the work to make sure she
could be on the dc circuit
shouldn't take long at all i don't know
three four five days ram that son of a
slam dunk that [ __ ]
i mean we don't have a carve out for the
supreme court justice for the filibuster
anymore don't need that that's not out
of the way thanks to republicans and amy
coney barrett they wanted to jam that
down our throat yeah well good for them
good for them
uh
caitlin's says uh
lindsay can have several seats
lindsay is upset
everyone says half half the court needs
to be women i believe it should be over
half caitlyn says it should be
i agree women make more than 50 of
americans they goddamn right it should
look like america the court should look
like america so they can make [ __ ]
decisions for america god damn it that's
what they're there to do
is to interpret the laws
in america so they should look like
america not a bunch of [ __ ] white
sweaty old ball sacks
give me a [ __ ] break okay uh number
four is trending uh ukraine invasion
we still have the ukraine invasion i
have um let's see
i have a video i'd like to show let's
see if i can find it real quick here um
it's kind of disturbing but i'm gonna
show it
and the reason why i'm gonna show it is
because i think it's very relevant to
what is happening
uh very very relevant
see
if i can find
the tweet
maybe it's been deleted it's possible
it's been deleted
yeah it looks like it's been deleted
um
maybe why i didn't i couldn't find it um
the the tweet was it was a video
and the video was
of an armored vehicle
rolling over a passenger car a russian
armored vehicle rolling over a passenger
car
um and obvious
what they were trying to do
um
trying to kill the person the people in
the car
it's a
very sad situation i'm sure
i'm sure that
putin is not going to be
not going to be put past of committing
war crimes here
usually
usually murderous dictating tyrants are
not past committing war crimes let's go
to the ghost of kiev because i can't
find this video i think i think the
video has been taken off twitter
um probably because of the graphic
nature of it i was willing to play it i
think we do not need to look away at
these things
we d listen and the people that really
need to have their their eyes filled
with these images are these [ __ ]
trump cult sheep these [ __ ] q anon
[ __ ]
you sick bastards you [ __ ] been
saying all this [ __ ] for years and years
and years here it is
you're cheering on putin
and he's doing what you're saying the
[ __ ] the
the liberal cabal wants to do get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
your little murderous dictator that you
love
is doing that good thing we have people
like that goes to kiev who is taking
down
russian
russian planes warplanes
six of them apparently
oh the aries is here tony i just saw the
video and the guy's alive you mean the
guy in the car is that is that what
you're saying
uh the ghost of cool kiev is the coolest
nickname i've ever heard that is a
pretty cool nickname
it is a pretty cool nickname
i'm not going to lie it's pretty [ __ ]
cool
pretty [ __ ] cool
and taking down
fighter jets russian fighter jets
there was an air fight that we were
watching yesterday and i i doubt i could
find that video back we played a lot of
video yesterday
i have some of these stuff that was
happening in ukraine because it was
happening in real time and people were
posting it all over the internet
um
let's see aries do you have do you have
that version of the video you're saying
there's a longer version of it now if
you have it uh dm it to me or tag me in
it and i'll see if i can pull it up here
um if you can find it and see
um
malcolm nance what one is this
russian threatens finland for joining
nato good reason to join in um yeah so
it looks like there's looks like there's
a moving news
um with ukrainian
border and you know i i actually this
morning i was thinking you know putin
might have another year or two here but
i don't know it may be months he may
have just months days weeks possibly
left here now with some of the pushback
from
from
some of the russian people
ukrainians standing and fighting for
their country
true ukrainian patriots
that want their freedom that want their
democracy even as even as unperfect as
ukrainians democracy is because you know
if you really get right down to it
ukraine has worked really hard on their
democracy to come as far as they have i
mean democracy is not [ __ ] easy it's
not we've seen that in the middle east
after we tried for decades and decades
to have democracy there democracy's
really [ __ ] hard
it's really [ __ ] hard because you
have to have a certain level of trust
for all people
it's really [ __ ] hard
but it's possible
again as imperfect as it is because
ukrainians democracy is not like all
[ __ ] peas and carrots you know it's
not [ __ ] sunshine and rainbows over
there
right
because it's difficult to make sure
that you actually give the voice to the
people
the people in power don't typically want
to do that
especially when you have murderous
tyrants that are in charge of the
government
it's difficult
it's very difficult to make that work
but you can and it's worth it every inch
every mile for democracy that you fight
for that's why those ukrainians over
there understand that they understand
that it's worth fighting for even as
imperfect as their democracy is
so when perfect is such that they're not
a nato ally maybe one day
they'll be part of nato
but they've got a long way to go with
their democracy
putin knows that too why do you think
he's trying to take advantage of that
that's a vulnerability
he wants he wants to have everyone in
the world question democracy wherever he
can because democracy is ultimately his
worst enemy
that's why
uh we're 48 minutes into the hour uh
here in just about 10 minutes or so
we're gonna i think we're gonna bring
rachel bitkoffer on you guys know rachel
so stay tuned for that rachel is a
political strategist um we were going to
talk about cpac but i'm sure we got a
lot of stuff to hash out here
um of of this uh war in ukraine uh cpac
you know you guys know cpax cpac
starting woohoo cpac
of course they should change the name to
cpac i think i'm gonna ask rachel that
question why are they still calling it
cpac max matt schlapp
schlapp
matt shalap went on steve bannon's
trader tv and said they're not
conservatives anymore they don't
consider themselves so why why don't you
change the [ __ ] name
to fpak fascist
fascist pack or maybe impact nazi i
don't know
i don't know
just pointing it out
just pointing that out oh mj says it's
her birthday too yeah i did i seen that
thank you mj for pointing that out it's
rachel's birthday she's joining us on
her birthday so you guys get to tell her
happy birthday so make sure when she
comes on
get your get your your chat ready and
wish her happy birthday we'll all try to
sing happy birthday to you well sort of
uh we'll all tell her happy birthday
uh when she gets on the show here we got
about 10 minutes until she comes in
what we'll do is we'll uh when she when
she's ready in the green room i'll go to
a break and then bring her in and then
you guys can wish you guys can wish
rachel happy birthday so put your
messages in now and i will i will bring
those up when we bring rachel on
to say happy birthday to her i know you
guys really like rachel and her insight
and that's that's what i want to ask her
today it's like what
what what does the messaging mean
because she's always focused on
messaging to get democrats some wins in
this country so that we can stave off
this fascist [ __ ]
so what is the messaging mean around
cpac what does the messaging mean around
the war that that putin has started in
ukraine against a sovereign country
trying to across a border and take a
country that is sovereign
a democracy trying to crush democracy
what does that mean and what does it
mean that you gqp the people at the seat
pack are standing on stage grandpa poopy
pants himself that [ __ ] sell out that
[ __ ] treason to sell out a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
standing on stage saying oh well
putin's smart
goddamn he got ukraine for two dollars
worth of sanctions
[ __ ]
vile [ __ ]
and what's more vile than that son of a
[ __ ] standing on stage saying that into
a microphone
then trump
capitulating to putin and his murderous
vile ways
is all the people who were listening to
him say that [ __ ] they weren't cheering
they weren't clapping
pay no mind they were eating all that
food was delicious it was so good i mean
god they paid hundreds of thousands of
dollars per plate
what do they care what did they care if
people are being killed in ukraine the
salmon was good
you [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
and this is who you've selected q and
honors gq peers trump culters
you [ __ ] make america great again
trump pumping idiots you've chosen those
people is who you think
you want to rule you
that's the oligarchy the people who were
eating the salmon
as donald trump talked about how
what a great transaction it was for
putin to take ukraine for two dollars
worth of sanctions no matter how many
bodies there are no matter how much
death there is you know how no matter
how much destruction there is what a
great [ __ ] deal that is what a great
[ __ ] deal it is
for putin
that's who you're choosing to be your
oligarchy
you [ __ ] trump pumping fools
that's what you're choosing
because as trump is selling out the
ukrainian people
as he's selling them out on stage
at a fundraiser
they're thinking they weren't cheering
and clapping trump
that's how sick these [ __ ] are
they were thinking oh this salmon is
great are you tasting the salad
how's your wine jan
we paid thousands and thousands of
dollars for this fancy plate of food
forget about forget about the the tyrant
wannabe talking about a murderous
dictator taking over a sovereign country
for two dollars worth of sanctions what
a great deal what a great real estate
deal that is
that's who you [ __ ] idiot trump
humping fools who think they're going to
bring back jobs and make america great
again that's the oligarchy that you're
choosing
to take over our country and be your
[ __ ] leaders to tell you what to do
to be the fascist
regime here the murderous regime here
you wouldn't last two [ __ ]
seconds in russia
you wouldn't last two [ __ ] seconds
under putin's rule not two [ __ ]
seconds you weak pieces of [ __ ]
oh i don't get my whopper i know what i
don't get my whopper because i chose not
to get vaccinated so that people
wouldn't get sick in my community and my
kids wouldn't have
we wouldn't have to worry about schools
and disease at schools oh i don't get my
[ __ ] whopper i don't get my
cheesecake
you don't know what [ __ ] liberty is
you have no [ __ ] clue you don't know
what it is and you don't know how to get
it
you have no idea
and if you [ __ ] even if you could
pluck your head out of your ass for two
goddamn seconds and understand that in
this country and other countries and
other democracies around the world
liberty is what we strive for and our
freedoms and our rights deliver us
liberty and it's not [ __ ] perfect
it's not perfect here it's not perfect
in canada and it definitely is not
perfect in ukraine but it's worth
fighting for
it's worth [ __ ] fighting for every
inch every millimeter it's worth
fighting for and i
i am telling you now
that you are on not only the wrong side
of history
but you are on the wrong side of the
world
and you better get straight and you
better [ __ ] you better open your
goddamn eyes
because putin will come for you too he
you will be the first that he comes from
you're the threat
wait until he kills democracy and then
see who he comes for as the threat
it's happened before
not just not just now
it happened during nazi germany
it happened during fascist italy
in japan it happened
don't think it don't don't think that it
won't happen to you you've trump pumping
fools so if that's the oligarchy that
you want who is who is oh
fawning over the salmon on the plate
while they listen to the wannabe
dictator talk about how
russia and putin are going in and taking
over a sovereign country a [ __ ]
democracy
because it's a good real estate deal
you sick [ __ ] that is not
america that is not america great again
it never will be it never has been
that's not democracy that's not liberty
that's not freedom
we have a a birthday that we have to
celebrate after the break we are so
excited to have rachel bitkoffer here
i'm sure she's going to have a few words
to say
about about the things that i just
stated
so stay tuned
rachel bitkoffer right after the break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
headlines
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around
maybe i'll cut that last ranch out
and uh post that post that on twitter
you guys can circulate that [ __ ] around
really [ __ ] [ __ ] in these gqp or
siller cereal
we have a we have a birthday to
celebrate
um we have a hey rachel how are you
happy happy [ __ ] birthday
man i gotta tell you this will be the
highlight of my birthday which is either
a backhanded compliment to you tony or a
sad testament to how sad my [ __ ] life
is
why i said you're in your pickup truck
right
i love i love when you join us in the
pickup truck yeah i do too in fact you
know i mean sometimes the nature of the
beast because i'm i'm like you know i
i'm basic i have a lot of jobs man
that's good well here i'll i'll make
your date uh caitlyn says happy birthday
rachel
um we have mj happy happy birthday let's
see if i can get my my mouse to work
here there it goes happy birthday happy
birthday happy birthday to you
happy birthday from lisa mayo says happy
birthday
so they love you here rachel and i miss
yoda says happy birthday ann says he's
weak to be a part tony and god i needed
what you just delivered right into my
veins so bad yeah well that's great well
tell me about that because i think i
think this is important um with with
because it's the one of the most vile
things that i've actually seen these
[ __ ] idiots do when donald trump
stood on the stage and basically talked
about
vladimir putin attacking ukraine uh with
which which there was no aggression from
ukraine murdering women and children
bombing apartment buildings residential
areas
um he's going to do a lot of killing a
lot of damage to that country all just
to bang up democracy and here these
people are eating salmon eating their
salad drinking their wine thousands of
dollars they paid for this fundraiser
for this plate it says maga behind the
[ __ ] it says make america great
again behind him oh [ __ ] none of a [ __ ]
is talking about how oh
two dollars worth of sanctions what a
great deal for putin
no [ __ ] dude why can't we get that
messaging and figure out how to make
sure that these [ __ ] are tied to that
we talk
by the balls right now tony
yeah we've got him by the balls right
now and there's no [ __ ] doubt about
it and you know here's the mode i mean
there's two reasons to do that number
one i mean for the
the uh
importance of making sure the electorate
knows what they're voting for in the
fall but also this i mean here's the
thing this situation in russia as you
were alluding to
uh with your little tour of world
history this is some complex [ __ ] and i
always knew that was complex but now
that i've taken this deep dive into
world civ let me tell you like this is
this is a messy [ __ ] situation with
putin because there's no doubt that he's
taking ukraine because he understands
what the nuclear arsenal that he has
nobody can really stand up to him other
than the ukrainians but you know let's
look down the road a bit i mean it's so
much like the sedatin land and the
beginnings of the rise of the hitler
regime in terms of its military
dominance um very very similar
circumstances and i think anybody would
be a fool to think putin isn't
interested in additional countries
especially within that nato circle so
you know this idea that we have to fight
our enemy now i mean this will be the
first time america's faced a major
conflict in which we have a domestic
[ __ ] enemy and that domestic enemy is
half of one of our major political
parties and so yeah we need to be coming
down on them hard we got to make make it
absolutely [ __ ] painful for them to
cow tail and uh you know do propaganda
for this [ __ ] dictator so i'm really
happy to hear you um highlighting it and
really making the case
well i think it's important and uh gabe
does too gabe's joining us here let me
uh let me uh
get get gabe in here because i know he
probably has some questions for you as
well hi gabe
hey course of course gabe always always
with the microphone oh no yeah i'm just
trying to be respectful while i'm in the
green room you know i'm hanging out
having snacks being quiet okay
do you have any questions uh for rachel
because i i know we're we always talk
about the messaging and and rachel we
did a whole show yesterday we watched
video we talked about the murders
dictator putin um continuously but gabe
did you have anything you wanted to ask
rachel
uh
i mean i think the biggest thing i think
that is that on everyone's minds is like
the
you know i think there's the potential
and obviously like the hope that that
the united front of both protesting
russians and those with that are in
ukraine as these ukrainian people also
there's that you know i think you did
you just play the the clip of the
fighter jet that i sent you this morning
yeah the the ghost of kiev which is
really [ __ ] cool did you see that the
hardest that is the hardest badass name
i've ever heard
right yeah i'm just [ __ ] familiar and
[ __ ] anyway
yeah no i look at that and i see this as
like an opportunity like if you know if
if putin as deranged delusional and
paranoid as he is like this
i guess it's not so much a question as
an observation it's like
there's a you know there is the
potential that
the normal average human both russian
and ukrainian has the opportunity to
stand up against a dictator
and a tyrant and actually defeat him
um you know and it's it's actually
very powerful to see right like because
you see this guy come in late at night
russians wake up to the to the news that
oh [ __ ]
we're at war now
and it's especially something that they
didn't ask for and now we're seeing that
there's actually like uh a solid front
you know people that are even you know
volunteering to deploy and find their
own way into ukraine to to
uh that aren't even russian or ukrainian
but just like normal canadian american
civilians that want to come in and help
um you know and aid them so
yeah i suppose i'm really lucky i'm not
healthy you know and young and
because i get that urge dude i want to
go over there and defend them too it is
so frustrating
understanding the geopolitical danger
that we're in with the nuclear
situation right so like i mean putin
knows he's got the world by its balls
and this in this endeavor and it is
because you know at the end of the day
ukraine once had russia's you know the
soviet union it had its own arsenal and
we
the world's like hey we'll take care of
you don't worry [ __ ] dude you know so
like the nuclear non-proliferation
effects of this are just so extreme but
here's the thing with putin do i think
he's i don't do i think he would
actually go and launch a nuke no i don't
i don't think so um but i don't i think
the complication of nuclear
fallout you know not literal fallout but
like the potential for a nuclear
engagement i mean it's just got
all of our nato not just us you know you
can only negotiate or
you know aggressively respond so far
without risking geothermal nuclear war
and that's why i think the pressure
really ought to be put on china right
because here's china's choice do you
want to be in the new world or the old
[ __ ] world make them choose
right um right now what emboldens russia
is that knowledge of having access to
chinese currency chinese markets i mean
it's a big [ __ ] economy
and at the end of the day like the most
effective thing that we could possibly
do in this such a situation is to is to
force china to walk away from supporting
this uh endeavor by russia even if you
know it's really not reasonable to
expect them to do anything other than
that but you know china's got it we got
to push china on this i think
yeah i think that
well i was going to say you know that's
a that's a good point because um
we've already seen that the gqp uh
tucker carlson and others have started
to backtrack you know you're saying
china to backtrack we've already seen
just just in the messaging here they've
realized that oh wait a second he was
actually serious as a murderous dictator
this wasn't just a [ __ ] game again it
wasn't just a [ __ ] game and i think
that's a good observation that not only
china but everyone else who's [ __ ]
decided they're gonna put in with putin
really better start to decide where
they're gonna put it right and that's
and that's what i'm trying to convey
about that that goddamn whatever
fundraiser that was that that piece of
[ __ ] was at
talking into the microphone acting like
ukraine was some kind of real estate
deal that no [ __ ]
bastard um and and and not only that but
the people sitting there just having a
great day with the steak and the salmon
and it was all fine and good and and
those people need to really start to
wake up and understand that
you're next you're next on his list i
don't know i just think that's a
messaging what do you guys do i didn't
mean to interrupt you
history is very clear about who who
comes next okay so like i mean here's
the thing all you all you putin enablers
out there that can hear my voice should
understand that if you ever get your
[ __ ] wish you will hate the world you
live in like the wife in in the
handmaid's tale that comes to regret her
life decisions that put her in a
subservient
anti-freedom place that chops her finger
off for [ __ ] reading okay tucker you
don't want to live there buddy and um
you know yeah you won't have to look at
gay people because they imprison them
and murder them in russia is that what
your ambition is for gay people here in
america i think inquiring minds like
mine would like to know i i think that's
a great point and i think that's why why
we need to hold these [ __ ] to the
fire and i and i don't just mean the
elected officials all of them and we
need to keep we need to keep giving the
airways to these morons saying the
stupid [ __ ] everyone's like oh don't
give tucker attention when he's cow
cowing to putin [ __ ] do not look
away don't look away
because i gotta tell you what we're
doing here tony and gabe and the
audience too and anybody who's listening
to us you know
this is this is not a [ __ ] game
all right even if you think the election
[ __ ] and you know staving off fascism
and blah blah blah is a game which i do
not even if you think that what's going
on here is if we do not
cow tail the radical element of the
republican party and obliterate them on
this particular issue
and quickly we may lose this
geopolitical battle to [ __ ] russia
okay you don't want to do that so we
really really really got to put pressure
on them for national security interest
as well as political interests i think
well gabe we we uh we we looked at a
letter yesterday about uh from general
michael flynn and there was something
that you tweeted uh
tell tell rachel that the part in the
letter that really pissed you off
oh the uh he goes through and then it's
at the final it's the butt right the
butt and which is which very much
reminds me of these like with that being
said you know it totally negates what
was just said right like you know you
may have an issue with what was done you
don't support the invasion the killing
of people but then if you have a but
this is what happens when you do x y or
z no shut the [ __ ] up you are now
negating everything that just came
before it so obviously your position is
that you do support putin and you do
want this to be in the position that
it's in and everything that you've put
in this letter is completely just like
moot it doesn't matter because we know
what your actual position is your
opinion is and how you feel about the
situation so don't come in with this
here's my official letterhead and my
signature and all this [ __ ] because
what you actually want is what is
happening
yeah yeah yeah and people like flynn and
tucker carlson especially carlson with
that big ass megaphone he has ought to
be considering what they can do for this
country right now right and what they
should not be doing is using their giant
[ __ ] multi-million viewer megaphone
to aid and abate our enemy and you know
to me that's trader behavior right and
uh tuck i don't think you want to be a
traitor dude
i mean just the idea that tucker would
go on the air and then say you know
you know using the the personal
anecdotes to be like has tucker ever
done this to you has tucker ever done or
sorry has well tucker has done all that
right right right right tucker's
probably eating dog too you know uh but
it for putin it's like oh has put never
done this has put never done this to you
you know like charlotte is like well i
guess he's never done this to me
personally but that type of narrative
that type of specific
the the the choice in words yes are very
deliberate and used to say well he's
never done anything to me personally so
i don't have a problem with them and
that type of narrative begins to shift
so that you say like well i guess he's
not so bad right he hasn't attacked me
personally so i don't have any qualms
with him
again just ignoring the fact of
poisoning journalists imprisoning people
killing people for the for being who
they are you know sexually you know
whatever like it doesn't matter the
point being like this guy is a you know
a wannabe dictator tyrant and his time
is coming to an end and we're seeing
that from the people who are standing up
against him who mind you these people
are risking their lives and i was
watching videos outside of you know i
saw some stuff from vice where they were
getting literally pulled away from cops
they're just protesting and saying no
war right that's the world
that they live in and that you know
putin wants which is anybody who speaks
out against me
done you either silent or you're in
support
yeah and it's worse than that gabe
because like that checklist that tuck
rolled out on his show about what putin
doesn't do to him okay when you think
about what it's collective message
because like it starts off with some
like pretty specific things and then it
gets into policy right he's like oh well
over there in russia i don't have to
have a boy playing on my girl's soccer
team right so it's not j he's aspiring
to a civilization that putin is creating
because along these culture war issues
okay
which which is so [ __ ] stupid because
it absolutely
absolutely discards or disregards the
fact that in russia tucker carlson
doesn't exist dude there's no [ __ ]
tucker carlson right and if he tried to
even say one thing about putin his ass
would be you know in one of these
russian prison camps dude so like oh
it's just so crazy to me that these men
have decided to aspire to an autocracy
just because they think and they they
they only think about how it will
benefit them and then at the end of the
day if they ever got their wish and we
started down that slope and we move into
one party rule in this country what
history tells us is all these enablers
all get [ __ ] killed jailed whatever
right
in the end so yeah we go first like all
the opponents of the opposition the
marginalized groups but at the end of
the day the butcher comes all the way
home to the hog well you you damn right
can you can you imagine
in vladimir putin's russia
if he required people to get vaccines to
go get a whopper from burger king and
they protest out in front of the burger
king can you imagine can you oh i got
arrested for
you know because i was a nuisance and i
got released with a fine and can you
imagine can you imagine the same
[ __ ] when they would be
treaded off to a camp because they were
just not not the sense of the mandates
you're a dissent of the leader you're no
[ __ ]
they don't understand when you're when
you're protesting and when you're
causing a ruckus and you're breaking you
know
laws in a town where you're causing a
disruption in a restaurant right on
private property and you're arrested
that's not the same it's not the same as
what putin would do to you
tony i gotta tell you too man i mean and
i'm not a concern i've never been a
republican i've never been a
conservative dude but i understand and
have studied all of the ideologies and
the intellectual philosophical
underpinnings of the ideologies and
there is nothing more antithesis to
intellectual conservatism than what that
[ __ ] that that that that anti-american
prophet kgb latin [ __ ] propaganda
coming out of fox news a major american
news station okay
the fact that he lives in a country that
is so [ __ ] free it's letting him run
russian kgb propaganda out of one of the
most you know populated news audiences
totally [ __ ] lost on him you know
well i i i think i think they're totally
lost on a lot of things yeah um you know
uh we we have an interview of course
we've had this russian news that we've
been we've been trying to play this
interview it's almost two hours um that
we've got um with an interview of
someone who's went through the data of
the uh the gibson go on the ottawa
truckers thing and it's it's not what it
appeared to be right it wasn't about
vaccines right that's not what it was
it's about anti-democracy and if you
look at the data you start to get
suspicious about
what what possible motives could happen
with the transactions that happened on
this gibson go like where's the money
coming from you know all these things
was it a test run for something you know
you get all these questions to start to
happen and i hope to play that interview
on monday or tuesday but don't you think
that not not just january 6 but we've
had many events that look like it we've
had all these nazi rallies that they've
had because a former president united
states doesn't go around doing rallies
that's not running for president that's
not a thing that happens it's not a
thing that happens right no
it's not not in a democracy you lost you
lost you lost you can run again and then
you can try to rally and win again go
build a library or something like that
right right well
the problem is the real the problem is
with the trump library it's going to be
more like a coloring book factory yeah
library it's like a like maybe a
coloring book factory slash like
outhouse you know kind of right right
really fun fact about trump well i'm on
board i found this out actually from
like a student that is was involved in
one of his works and so had gone down to
mar
largo and i think enough times passed
now no one will be able to identify the
students so anyway she was telling me
down in mar-a-lago in the kitchens they
have every kind of fast food burger
right that you could ever want and it's
all set up in this like microwave system
with all the like the specific heating
instructions from each of the chains
provided to people
i just can't you know
i know i haven't been able to
independently verify this but it sounds
so [ __ ] on point but uh you know who
knows but yeah i figured you'd enjoy
that i don't know yeah
you remember what
what sports team was it it was in the
white house and he was like oh we're not
going to serve him food we're going to
get a mcdonald's or something wasn't it
it was uh it was it was uh nc nc double
a basketball right yes
the conversation actually now that you
mention it because i i mentioned that in
class and that's when the story got
relayed to me i was like oh god that's
so [ __ ] because you know he's got a
fast food addiction right so like
like literally his own [ __ ] little
like restaurant down there like with all
of his faves from whichever burger king
and mcdonald's and [ __ ]
well you know you know i actually
encourage donald trump to eat at least
four big macs a day
large fries kfc eat a whole bucket of
chicken you fat [ __ ]
nothing nothing says into fascism like a
little bit of heart disease that's all
i'm saying yeah i'm not rich and ill
upon anyone i'm just you want to
accelerate it a bit i mean i don't think
i don't know if you guys remember this
but after the after he lost the election
the like the first or second time uh he
was
he was gorging he was eating all of the
hamburgers and all the fast food and it
was so bad that there were reports
coming out that aids had to like
[ __ ]
spritz down the place and light candles
and make sure it didn't smell because he
would it just smelled like it was just
like like like birdies hearts or what
yeah it was it was just like they i
think the official word was flatulence
but it was just it was soaking in like i
i swear the person whoever flips the
white house to get ready for the next
presidency was like steam wall in the
[ __ ]
ripping down
so you had to flip the cushions on the
sofa yeah they're like listen we
normally put this in storage but we're
gonna have to burn this [ __ ]
here's the thing though let me interrupt
real quick because i think this
this means we gotta we've gotta ask our
friend at patriot takes who seems like
to get some [ __ ] some good [ __ ] out of
mar-a-lago in terms of photos right go
get us a photo of that [ __ ]
kitchen dude i want to see that supply
change
right yeah yeah well you know that's
that i i again
i've had you know experience with fast
food farts flatulence as as gabe calls
it yeah i can't imagine the amount of
food that this guy eats as fat [ __ ]
seeks uh speaking of that
going back to how to tie this in to the
little video that he had um his little
nazi video where he's talking about how
great it is that russia and putin has
made this big real estate deal uh
you know basically [ __ ] all over the
people who are dying in ukraine that are
being killed and
what's funny at the very end of that
clip
he says and i want to thank ronnie
jackson do you guys know who ronnie
jackson is remember right now he's the
one that stood on stage and debased
himself and said
donald trump is the healthiest human
being i've ever he weighs 102 pounds
i'd be like
tony i mean come on dude i mean you're
going to see that it's not like it's
[ __ ] invisible dude
we can only
i just i can't understand how how uh
ronnie jackson as a doctor would debase
himself but but the greatest part is is
when he's standing in that room when
he's standing in that room that's the
one person the one person that he picks
out that called him thin that called him
the healthiest person in the world
one person out in that moment and and
and and he's ronnie jackson stands up
and that's where everything's running
where's ronnie where's my where's my
little ronnie come right here right like
that's what he is right and that guy has
sold his soul for he will forever be you
know indebted to him and i'm sure he's
got something on him and i i just like
also no one else is gonna [ __ ]
respect that guy to be like yeah this
guy's bmi was totally within the normal
range he was a healthy weight
sound mind and sound body he totally
passed that cognitive test like all of
these things where you're like i highly
doubt your professional and medical
opinion right now because it needs dog
[ __ ] at this point
yeah that's what i i mean you guys are
going to see this
coming up in an interview that will
release soon i'm like you know the
problem is once you deliver me a bunch
of [ __ ] like then everything else
you say is like meaningless right so you
know that's one reason why to live in
reality land where you know things are
actually true because once you're full
of [ __ ] about one thing all right and so
ronnie jackson my guess here too guys
and i don't know this for a fact but i
know that it's true
is a pill slinger right and that's
probably why
he had to go out there and debase
himself but i don't know if you guys
remember he got kicked out of the white
house or slinging opioids to the staff
or you know off prescription that's just
kind of little legal yeah well i mean
i'm sure yeah like you said i'm sure
that behavior was not new to his tenure
at the white house it was probably
before that as well and of course was
like well this is the only job i can get
these days so [ __ ] i'm all in you
know not anymore now he's running for
office as a republican
oh
isn't that fantastic so so i mean i mean
that's that's the other thing i want to
talk about before we go here is that
this putin thing this this this putin
infatuation that these idiots like mike
flynn have been perpetuating to get
their followers to get on the side of
authoritarianism because that's really
what it is they're trying to push their
followers to be more authoritarian
because that serves their purpose but
how do we in in in a race against ronnie
jackson how do we how do we say hello
wake up what's the messaging that we use
in this country to make sure people know
oh the putin thing that's one thing
that's going to happen to you what what
do we do about the message because i
know this strategic outrage is always um
you're right up your alley to make sure
that the messaging's on point so how do
we tie
not just mike flynn but how do we make
all the gqp mike flynn a a a putin
capitulator how do we do that it's not
hard at all guys i mean they've really
served us up unfortunate circumstance
where i mean
not insignificant and chill i mean the
party is deeply divided on this issue
right now and luckily
luckily figuring out that actually in
some of the most important states in
2022 there are significant populations
of white ukrainians that they need to
vote for them right so like you know
i only mention that because they're
never going to do anything for the good
of america they need a
a motivation so let's hope that that
kind of cow tales some of this effort
but the fact of the matter is public
opinion flows from the top down
republicans have invented a system based
on joseph goble system in in nazi
germany to control information flow and
create a media ecosystem that they
control and they've done that in 20
something years right now and on that
media ecosystem if you're seeing you
know even 30 of the programming trying
to to not only normalize
authoritarianism autocracy and in the
case of
putin i would say totalitarianism you
are trying to sell it you're he's
they're selling the vision imagine this
white audience of mine
tucker carlson here obviously imagine
this utopia where there's no gay people
in your face and you know da da da da
like they you know they so what my point
is
is that this is so easy to explain to
people this is not a challenge at all
freedom democracy autocracy and
dictatorship right and you just have to
make sure that when you're doing that
people can see themselves in that
calculus and it's not just about people
elsewhere so it's really important that
we um always condition our advertising
and what i call that me frame and not
the we collective because unfortunately
for us like we're the we people and
we're just not a very big chunk of the
electorate
you know uh someone the other day
tweeted a an acronym for g.o.p and i
think it was i think it was uh someone
maybe i know it was grand old putin
g.o.p
grand old putin so i mean i think i
think that's an easy way to do it i mean
maybe not in the exact words but to say
look the gqp is the party of putin
there it is and what we do what we do is
we drive wedges because i think they
they are ultimately divided on this
issue for obvious reasons and we should
drive wedges in those obvious reasons
right and drive wedges in between them
and break up their electorate in some of
these districts i think it is possible
that they
are vulnerable dude
they were already vulnerable because of
ron johnson and if i was able to run the
whole country strategy right uh they
were already hella vulnerable all three
of those midwestern states exactly for
these demographics that i was just
talking about and because ron johnson is
literally like your quintessential
tucker carlson in elected office right
he is just as bad says just as terrible
[ __ ] and is just as busy trying to sell
people in the vision of living in an
autocracy right but now it's not even
abstract now it's it is all you know a
big chunk of the party it is a
definitional moment for republicans and
it there is a huge value in going in
there and hitting their own
you know electorate in a targeted way on
this issue and and making that choice
very clear
america versus putin right are you on
team america and you know team america
is not the republicans right now are you
with putin and the republican party
and i think i think we can drive wedges
in in those areas between the uh
republican electorate and the
conservative the gop electorate the
trump electorate we really can draw
those stark issues now rather it's now
rather it's those people go and vote for
a pro-democracy candidate which right
now as we see in this country there's
only one party that stands behind
democracy that's right full-throated so
and we need
everyone knows that tony because here's
the thing you know that gabe knows that
the audience knows that twitter knows
that and but the idea that out there and
i'm luckily in my truck so i can look
out in the world out there everybody
knows that not unless we [ __ ] tell
them we have to tell them that
well and we got to do it over and over
and over and over again because that
works it works to repeat these messages
and pound it in brains and
where to where people are tired of it
because because i think i think you
tweeted something um last week or the
week before about tom brady's
retirement and deflated football like
literally more people know the
circumstances around tom brady retiring
then what it means to have fascists like
putin to take over our country and what
it means for football like you wouldn't
have the nfl
that thing would not exist in the way
that it exists they would get rid of the
majority of people who play in the nfl
yeah no [ __ ] dude like that's what they
would do
it just it baffles me every single time
that we that that it it's so hard to
convince these people that hey you're
say you're for freedom and liberty but
ultimately you don't know what it is and
it's obvious that you don't because
you're
you're thinking that the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
liberty and it's not yeah you do not get
to
freely oppress the rights of other
people that's not liberty that is the
opposite of liberty and you need to come
to the side of actual liberty and know
that equality and equity is going to
deliver it to you yeah and in case any
actual conservatives ever [ __ ] listen
to this i'm gonna just say and that's
the opposite of natural law too right i
mean it's a perversion of the idea of
natural law because a lot of the um
philosophical basis for individualism
like hyper individualism that i would
call now because it used to be rugged
individualism now at the gop what people
with certain elements of the gop are
propositioning is hyper right it's a
hyper version of that
and so you know we really just need
people to understand autocracy versus
democracy in 2022. one party's for
democracy one party's for autocracy and
that is an easy message now because um
putin's the kind of
story that everyone knows you know what
i mean so like in uh the american
conscious it's not going to be hard for
people to to see what's happening in
ukraine in a way that affects them here
and i i think that's correct and i think
that's why you see a lot of even tucker
carlson trying to back away from his
statements the g and we should not let
them back away we should make them
answer for their statements because i
believe that's partly why putin
is braving what he's doing no yeah no
you know that's all part of his strategy
right so like so important i mean i i
always talk about how oh here we are in
22 and we're in this republican playbook
that's been ongoing now for about 25 30
years it's been edited a few times
updated change but it's a strategic
[ __ ] plan and it has like five-year
10-year goals and now we're sitting in
there like their 20-year goal on media
and you know 10-year goal and digital
10-year goal and electoral reform so you
know putin's plan was destabilize the
west around the issues of racial
grievance help do that because it's
already there and i can amplify that
gets more than he could have ever
[ __ ] hoped for because his dumb [ __ ]
celebrity
corrupt criminal manages to win the
nomination end the general election and
becomes president of the united states
and for four years putin has sowed the
seeds of division here domestically
because at the end of the [ __ ] day
guys if we can't get tucker carlson to
shut the [ __ ] up what's gonna happen is
we're not gonna see a rally around the
flag effect for the first time in
american [ __ ] history we're not gonna
see the population rally around the flag
after pearl harbor okay some you know
i'm not talking about like way you know
with war in world war ii i'm talking
about after being actively you know
engaged in it so we really have to put
pressure on them for more than politics
is literally depending on the state of
of the world to keep these people from
turning half the republican party into a
machine
well i do appreciate you coming on as
always you are always welcome back
hopefully we can get you on next week we
can find i i i know we had trouble with
your schedule this week i know there's
some some good things coming because of
that so i'm excited um and also
gabe did you did you know that it's
someone's birthday did you know that i
saw i saw in the comments i wanted to
wait for like asylum so i could say
happy birthday yeah so so everyone
everyone thanks for wishing great rachel
happy happy happy birthday and we are so
happy to have you on during your
birthday it's my privilege man getting
to hang out my few favorite boys like
this on my birthday i love it so thanks
guys hope you have a good day we will
we'll see you soon and everyone stick
around we're going to do bonehead of the
week right after the break stick around
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopers mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the troop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew feed the
spread you want to see in the world
twitch stream the [ __ ] list roundup at
twitch.tv slash the tony michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
happy birthday again to rachel [ __ ]
offer one of our
favorite
regulars here on the tony michael's
podcast we love it we love it we're
gonna do bone end of the week gabe how
are you good how are you i just saw you
a moment ago like well i know but yeah
we're on bone end of the week i didn't
get to say howdy you know we had to
bring you on you did the whole mic thing
again it just it's a continuing problem
with you know what i mean oh my god i
did it again sorry i was like you know i
was like into it i was making sure that
the video was yeah well i i i want to i
want i want to say that maybe eventually
we will have to work gabe on the bone of
the week because he just can't i mean he
just
can't figure out that
i think there was a person on here this
week that kept calling you tony montana
and
well you know that that that i i think i
think uh that was uh vladimir putin uh i
think is who you're referring to now i i
i will i will say yesterday i did i did
have a bit of trouble with my mic uh so
i i do want to tell on myself a little
bit yesterday a little bit of trouble i
pulled the game and couldn't get the mic
oh it sounds like somebody can relate
you know yeah well you know i i i still
like to give you [ __ ] yeah yeah i mean
who doesn't know my parents do you do
everybody oh okay okay so this is an
ongoing thing not just with me yeah
listen it's not new you know it's an
established uh
type of pattern yeah you know okay well
i also i like your hat by the way today
oh yeah well you know
yeah you want the the actual
usa you know the the one that not the
ussr right yeah right right right i'm
not trying to go back to the ussr i'm
not trying to live in a fascist state
i'm trying to live in an america that we
are all proud of that okay
is great it was great it's been great
obviously we have some growing pains we
have to deal with right now we can get
greater i think i think we can yeah we
can improve ourselves like we're not
like you know i think
the us america is
uh
like any human is
imperfect right and we have flaws we're
inherently flawed we're selfish we're
greedy you know we're dumb we saw that
all of 2020 and 2021 and continue to see
that today
but i hope
that through that you know we have the
opportunity to learn from our mistakes
and grow out of them you know it's kind
of like those like teenage years or like
oh man i was so like angsty and i made
all these mistakes and i got in trouble
and all this [ __ ] right
maybe you're just kind of on the wrong
path i'm hoping
that you know
the u.s is pretty is still pretty young
i'd say and so i'm hoping that this is
one of those like growing pains that we
like get our [ __ ] together and go wow
you know i will [ __ ] up back then you
know i i had i had a fri i have a phrase
for this it's it's pluck your head out
of your [ __ ] asses that's kind of my
you know how i do you gotta you gotta
pluck your head out of your ass and you
know come to your right right right and
realize that what you've been saying
what you've been propagating probably
isn't the best message not just for here
but around the world and it's going to
affect you in reality it's not a game
it's not just a thing you're posting on
social media for fun and games the
little game that you're playing with
putin and how it's fun to support him
that's not a [ __ ] game it's real [ __ ]
so yeah speaking speaking of people who
do really stupid things let's start
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we love the music here at mohan of the
week it's uh it's a it's a great thing
i'll get to watching cartoons you know
yeah well you know it's it's a good
entry into the moment um here's our
contestants this week um vladimir putin
if you guys know who that is uh donald
trump and tucker carlson these are all
really like it's just putin right
this week they are already tied together
rip off the mask and reveal who donald
trump was it was putin tucker crawford
it was putin so right right so like
basically this week the bone end of the
week is putin no matter who was be
selected obviously the winner is
vladimir putin uh himself where did you
get this picture where did you get this
picture
you know i always make sure to get the
worst photo for these people you know i
i never want them smiling
uh this is uh i think that photo
i i typed in vladimir putin face sad
into google image search and uh that's
what popped up and then it's just like
so you know uh i think that's satomir
putin satomir uh that's that's even
better salamir putin now we don't we
don't have a lot of time for the bone in
the week because we we didn't have each
one but
but we do want to go through a few
things here um obviously for obvious
reasons we we know why vladimir putin's
on this list we've been talking about it
for the last two or three days uh
puppeteer yeah well and we had vladimir
putin on the show you booked him i i
don't know why you
good that connected or like booked in
the putin yeah i don't know where he's
gone he's like off the grid like oh
really so like
that maybe he dissented or something
maybe he was i don't know like is he
alive still i don't know like is he in a
gulag somewhere i have no idea you're
saying we may never get putin back
that's the only putin interview we may
ever do that was my that was my putin
connection oh okay well you know maybe
earlier earlier on the show you said put
in with putin and i was like oh that's
so good because it's putin yeah put it
with putin is that what i said and did i
say that you said i'd say a lot of
things
put in and i was like oh that's good
because it's did you tweet that go tweet
it right now go ahead okay okay all
right i'm going go tweet that make sure
you quote me though god damn it don't
um so so the other the other thing that
we have this week because we always do
dishonorable mention but we don't have a
lot of time but i want to go through
this some of this stuff um because you
tucked tail on me and ran on to simon
mentioned and you went with lindsey
graham we had we had more of them that
were supposed to go but lindsey graham
so why did you put lindsey graham as the
dishonorable mention because
lindsey
tom
lincoln lips
what the [ __ ] lips graham
um the reason i put him on there is
because of the uh his recent comments or
his recent tweet that he made about uh
biden's
um
new scotus nominee
and the reason that he's dishonorable
mention is because if you want to pull
that up yeah let let me uh what's what's
uh let me just search
let me search lady g here um
yeah if you look up uh lindsey graham i
don't know face face uh baseball uh if
you look up
uh
so so is it a tweet is it yeah it's a
tweet and then he's got a little and
then he's got a sub tweet underneath
what is it what is it on his official
account or was it yeah yeah yeah okay
let's see
and did he do
let's just let's let's pull in the um
let's pull it in here and see you can
see it but so where are we looking here
he's he's tweeting a lot
how far are we in we're 21 hours in no
up up up hour in that's lindsay
yes scroll down scroll down yep there's
putin there's that what's up yes jackson
is this it if
your reports are accurate judge jackson
has been chosen the supreme court
nominee to replace justice breyer it
means that the radical left has won
president biden over
yet again the attacks by the left
no like that's [ __ ] because you want
to know why that's [ __ ] is because
he has
he voted yes to confirm her in june of
2021.
wait wait wait wait wait what year what
is the 2020 how how long ago was that
that seems like it's so far ago look
look it's like i'm a mathematician but
it's less than 12 months right okay
right uh but what he said was you're
saying wait you're saying that lady g
lindsey graham was for judge jackson
before he was against her is that what
you're saying
um
that would be correct okay well and i'm
sure there's a voting record somewhere
that would prove yeah and there's even a
quote and it says i think she's
qualified for the job she has a
different philosophy than i do but it's
been that way the whole time
this is what he said
when he voted yes to confirm kantanji
brown jackson's nomination for the dc
circuit court of appeals
which happened in june of 2021
now
i think
this type of [ __ ]
is is so dumb because he goes oh the
radical the left is taking over
you [ __ ] voted for this dude you said
yes you vetted her you looked through
you said she's qualified she knows what
she's doing we agree we disagree on
policies and and have a different uh uh
way of thinking
but
i accept and i say yes and i confirm her
to go through
so
that in in less than a year
don't try to pull that [ __ ] out of your
ass and say actually it's the left's
taking over and clearly they got a hold
of biden sorry they didn't pick whatever
person you wanted but it's not your
choice it's not your nominee
and don't come in here and all of a
sudden say well i don't know if she's
qualified right
is it maybe because the nominee wasn't
white i don't know
i mean you know the dc circuit of
appeals is a little different court than
the supreme court and well it sounds
like for example for people who don't
know the dc circuit of appeals
that the court of appeals is like a
is like a feeding ground
for
right supreme court that's that's where
that's where that's where judges go to
be supreme court right exactly yeah but
the point i was trying to make is it
sounds about white that you would want
her on the supreme court of appeals not
on the supreme court it sounds about
white i'm just saying yeah
so this is the follow-up this is the
subtweet i think you were talking i
expect a respectful but interesting
hearing
in the senate judiciary committee which
is where they nominate and confirm to
get to the senate floor the harvard yale
trained uh to the supreme court
continues
to run
unabated
what was the sub is that the one that
you were talking about yeah that's the
one our need so it the way that i look
at it is like he
tweeted so like what time was the first
week
uh
four hours ago and then this one is at 8
34 so
um a few hours after that okay
so i look at this and i say he said
something maybe he saw what was
happening i don't know uh maybe i saw
maybe he saw maybe he saw the [ __ ]
the quote tweets and the [ __ ]
comments look at this ratio here
is blocking ratio 6 300 comments 1200
likes
yeah it's pretty bad so i i look at this
and i say oh did you know did he come in
here to like course correct a little bit
where he's like oh it's the left
but i also expect a respectful but
interesting hearing in the senate
judiciary committee the harvard yale
train to the supreme court continues to
run unabated like
that's him being like oh well the
supreme court justices have been from
like ivy league schools and she's all
she also went to harvard and harvard law
school so like
the trend continues and it's like dude
why why would you need to justify that
for her being a qualified candidate
right she's got 30 years in
in um
in uh and
uh criminal justice reform you know
she's got experience she's she's
well i mean i mean to to be to be
straight out
black women in america are the most
educated population in america 100
there are more college-educated black
women than any other um
group of people than there is
percentage-wise they are the most
educated in this country there are
plenty not just not just uh
judge judge brown judge jackson
there there are a whole list
of
black women that were that were
considerations for nominees on this seat
the supreme court not only not only
consideration but 100
probably 200 qualified a lot more than
any of the [ __ ] justices that donald
trump even nominated and they got on the
seat so this idea that you can't put uh
because that's what this is about if he
would have nominated
you know
a white ball sack as i call him a white
crusty old ball sack
they'd be fine lindsey grant be all
excited oh excited to see
this white dude i don't think lindsey
graham ever brought up uh amy coney
barrett's nope uh you know
probably my education history was like
oh the notre dame like you know it's
like no or you know whatever
anyway i look at this and i i see him
trying to somewhat course correct to be
like well i didn't mean it how i meant
it you know it's like no you meant it
how you meant it right this is this is
so when he gets in front of the press
they ask him he said well i had a
follow-up yeah right i was clear i was
like
yale pro harvard yeah
respect respectable even though i called
her a leftist you know right exactly or
like the left took control of biden you
know and it's like what does that even
mean you did you voted for this his
nominee
right in 2021 right and said she was a
she was a perfect nominee you disagree
she's qualified exactly so i look at
this and the other thing too i i think
that they're probably more afraid of is
the fact that now
we have a qualified woman
a person of color who is who is uh you
know very smart talented has the
experience to go in and actually shape
these policies going you know for also
for someone who is relatively young you
know going in and shaping the policies
and laws of this country
to better
us as a whole as
instead of just a single group but also
you know
keep in mind that this should be
uh uh you know a hit like hit it out of
the park you know it should be pretty
pretty streamlined because she's already
been vetted less than a year ago right
there's not much between now and then
that it could come out she was vetted in
2013 when obama nominated her to the
last seat she was on and she got
confirmed for that so you look at that
and it's like well this should be pretty
easy you guys already did the paperwork
there was not much that happened in 10
months outside of her leaving her house
and going to the grocery store right and
going to work right so the other thing
too i think that they're also probably
afraid of is the fact that oh oh my god
oh no we have a woman a person of color
who's going on the bench
okay that's a big problem but also she's
leaving that position which means that
body now gets to nominate another person
who could potentially be another woman
person of color
and and a qualified supreme court
nominee exactly fantastic
i love your thought process but i think
also that they're terrified is to show
that uh not only are black women
qualified to do anything in this country
but they are they are well well well
capable of being a very good supreme
court justice for a very long time i
think that's right they're terrified
that people will see that they'll
respect that and it will continue to
happen which is a good thing because her
her opinion is going to be
written
in the law her
dissented opinion is going to be for
everyone to be able to read for years to
come throughout the rest of uh you know
usa history it will be down that she had
a say
on what was brought before
the justices and what her say was that
exactly that's perfect so [ __ ] lindsey
graham who's our uh we got an alpha cuck
here um peter peter ducey what what did
peter ducey do what did what did peter
do see not do you well then
that may be a better question i guess
what peter ducey did or did not
maybe i'll search this up here um is it
what what specifically did you put ducey
on the uh
there was uh he had a moment this week
where he was asking questions i i think
he uh he had an encounter with president
biden
uh also another gensake
uh ukraine question
um
okay so here here is a couple um this is
16 hours ago was this yesterday
um it says i don't think news and
documentary emery is in peter ducey's
future i just can't see it i loved him
is this is this the clapback you're
talking about let's look yeah yeah i
think this is the one you think right
now putin is improvising and adapting
but you've also said that you very much
anticipate and predict that he's going
to invade further so which is it is he
adapting or is he still invading
think big here
peter we've said and that continues to
be the case while making adaptations on
when if how to what his strategy is
that's what we're seeing both are true
oh my god someone entered jinsaki into a
slam dunk contest please think big
peter peter i know it's hard but i need
you to think big picture i like open
your mind open your mind to other
possibilities just understand that
you can be both of those things you
could be doing both of those things yes
oh that's [ __ ] hilarious so he so he
did really get alpha cooked i like that
you put him in the office you know
another another um ducy that did some
stupid [ __ ] this week is the governor of
arizona ducey did you see his little
thing about when you were honored he's
like oh i'd much rather have the fascist
nazi rogers than the democratic yeah
yeah so we got we maybe we should have
been i know he he would have been a good
candidate was that who you wanted well
well i mean i i i don't decide these
things right right that the universe
does the universe decides these things i
just make suggestions but another ducey
different spelling also a viable
candidate for the well you know what why
we're doing that why don't we uh why
don't we go to the doozy video because i
think it's worth as we're pounding on on
that ducey's here for for alpha cuck
well let's let's do she's baby
that that's good that's a good one the
douchies let's see uh if i can find yeah
here's the video i believe this is it
maybe that should be an award i mean
like hi and today we present you with
the dude
yeah i don't know you know we're adding
a bunch of uh content here we have the
apple cuck we got the dishonorable
engine now we have the douchies i mean
it's possible that these two could
possibly be on the show every week we
definitely
peter ducey could definitely be but this
is this is the governor ducey of arizona
and here's what he says about wendy
rogers i don't know if you guys know
this but windy rogers is basically said
yeah i want to be a nazi i'm a nazi all
all but just say also the worst takes
oh my god
i mean it's it's actually sometimes
that's like you you couldn't even make
parody of the [ __ ] that she says it's
how bad her [ __ ] takes her it's kinda
like what's that bridget uh bridget
gabriel almost the same yeah gabriel
yeah yeah thanks almost copied twitter
accounts let's listen to what let's
listen to what peter ducey thinks about
nazis being in the government other than
independent democrats universal spent
about a half million dollars helping to
get wendy rogers elected to the senate
she's taking off as she's
extremely controversial it's kind of
openly associated with basically white
nationalist movies they're trying to
move the republican party and
conservative moving in that direction
given all this
he's really pissed off here that he's
like yeah i know that she's a white
nationalist and i hate that you brought
that up because now i'm gonna have to
side with a white like you can see it on
his face because he can't he can't not
side with her here he can't yeah
right he's got you i mean there's yeah
there's no way you know especially a
sitting
uh politician you're like there's no way
that he cannot go with the party because
if he says no to someone who supports
white nationalism
or or supremacy or you know anything
that is uh
[Music]
racist
uh then what ends up happening is that
that's an that sense of ripple through
the party to say
oh [ __ ] we're saying no to this stuff
uh we're going to lose voters
right
and we're going to get we're going to
get uh we're you know basically we're
going to get either primary or we're
going to be seated or right you know
well they want the let's go brandon
nazis let's face it right so and i i
want to point out here
maybe since we're on the alpha cuck
isn't this face here this freeze frame
here does this not look like someone who
just
you just got you just got kicked yeah
okay yeah i just want to make sure let's
let's move on here you're still happy
with that investment you believe that
was a good decision
what i need is as a governor uh
governing majorities so that i can pass
dollars that's actually not what you
need you just need a legislator you
don't need majorities i mean if you can
compromise you can you can get a
majority of vote right social safety net
so we can provide pro that's this
fascist [ __ ] that's his fascist [ __ ] the
only way the only way is to is to to not
compromise to push our views on someone
like this that will help children from
all over our state the fact that we can
pass budgets that put 8.6 yeah got to
say the words children got to say budget
billions
and she's still better than her opponent
felicia french what do you think of that
kind of wing of the conservative
movement that she represents well i said
she's better than felicia french so
she's so she's better than a democrat
having a nazi as the nominee arizona the
florida of the west
well nick martin says arizona governor
doug i almost said peter doug ducey um
was asked today how he feels about state
lawmaker wendy rogers in light of her
recent embrace of white nationalist
movement recent [ __ ] reese of my ass
ducey told reporters it's better than
having a democrat in office that's right
nazis nazis
neo-nazis white nationalist
fascist outright fascist much better
much better than than someone who's
pro-democracy you know those radical
things like yeah i don't know education
i i don't want other people to have a
say so i'm going to make to say for them
right i like putin sounds like
who is our bonehead of the week
vladimir putin so let's let's give him
his do here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
vlady daddy vladimir putin the the
puppet of the gqp
uh now or maybe gop grand old putin as
gabe points out so thanks thanks putin
for coming on the show this week yeah
we're gonna have a we're gonna if you
don't see us next week guys you know why
you [ __ ]
that [ __ ] idiot uh well i i i'll say
one more thing on putin here that
in all seriousness
i actually before he invaded um i
thought maybe putin had another 10 or 15
years to reign in russia and then once
this uh this escalated to the point
where they were on the border and it
looked like he was going to invade what
the administration has said is to be
true the timing's been a little
different but he's actually pushed
further forward than what i think that
they had publicly uh you know shown and
there's been more more bombing and more
war
a quicker amount of time than what maybe
people thought
i actually think that putin's time
was reduced to about two years as
reigning in russia when he was on the
border i think it's being reduced um by
months every single hour that he oh yeah
i mean they put it you know biden put
him in a position where you know it you
know they didn't take force they didn't
take action you know there wasn't
anything to really like instigate that
movement he went unwarranted
and invaded right now
he looks like he wasn't like oh i'm
reacting because somebody shot me or
somebody did this or whatever it's like
no no you went in the middle of the
night
and decided to invade
and you went under false pretenses and
rather no reason at all right so the
delusional paranoid uh
whatever you want to call them like the
guy is
he's he
again like he wasn't reacting to
anything he was he was
preemptively doing something and now he
is obviously the you know he looks like
the villain in this situation which he
is right well and i'll tell you i'll
tell you that tyrants the timeline for
tyrants it seems like putin's timeline
he's really speeding it up here so
thanks vladie daddy for being our bone
end of the week stick around after the
song
we're gonna finish up here with some
announcements
[Music]
[Applause]
all right welcome welcome back to the
regular show uh that was a good that was
a good bonehead of the week i i figured
vlady would take it take it yeah really
i was i was surprised that there were as
many votes for uh trump and tucker i
mean since they're just talking heads
for putin well but again it's kind of
you know vladimir
vote for putin when you're voting yeah
a vote for him is a vote for putin right
right right absolutely absolutely so we
have a few announcements we have this
interview that we're wanting to air of
course we've had this russian stuff
happen this week so we've kind of had to
put it off but i think monday or tuesday
is our aim for that we'll let you guys
know it's a very good episode it's going
to be take up a whole a whole episode i
believe
so maybe we'll do it on tuesday possibly
monday we'll just see what some of the
news brings
i'm hoping to get it up we really want
to do that um on the show live so stay
tuned for that also uh go follow go
follow um at tony michael's pod if you
want to vote for bonehead of the week
this week i know we were late um we were
working with the news but follow tony
michael's pod go vote for bonehead of
the week next week that way you can get
your vote in on next week because every
friday we do the bonus of the week in
the second hour thank you rachel happy
birthday thanks for coming on the show
today um also remember every single
weekday noon eastern 11 central right
here on youtube twitter twitch don't
forget to like subscribe uh go to go to
gabe's link in his bio go to my link in
my bio show us some support if you can
and retweet like have a great weekend
and
until
monday at noon surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking